[Music]
Scrat the saber-tooth squirrel waited
until it was very much winter to find a
place to bury as one acorn also this
stupid prehistoric squirrel only has one
acorn for the winner also saber-tooth
squirrels never existed not off to a
good start moving how was this thing not
already dead I know it would be kind of
dark for this movie for kids to open on
a prehistoric squirrel carcass but I may
prefer that to teaching kids that ill
preparedness is hilarious Ruby expects
me to believe that ice cracking has a
similar behavior to a lit line of
gunpowder did the second glacier just
happen to be falling or did another
dumbass critter serendipitously cause
this one to fall at the same time
scratch is dead scratch is dead oh don't
really scratch is dead I mean that's
totally the end of scratch right I mean
Jesus I guess I don't have to ever worry
about scrap I saw a dead squirrel once
my God have mercy on my soul if I figure
out whatever monster or Toyota Camry did
it why not call it the Big Chill or the
NIP Fiero
because then there would be no naming
option for the porn parody of this movie
also if there are that many animals then
why the fuck wasn't Scrat immediately
stepped on the other 99% of the herd
seems to just appear out of nowhere how
do we know it's an Ice Age you wouldn't
for two reasons you know or anyone you
know would only know the world as it is
because an ice age lasts for thousands
of years and also these creatures are
probably experiencing a glacial period
within an ice age since we are
technically still in an ice age today
see you probably didn't know that now
you can relate to these armadillo
pig-nosed creatures no fudge
you can play extinction later first of
all this is incredibly morbid second of
all with the herd moving like it is how
are these kids able to break away from
their parents to play in this tar pit in
the first place someone sucks at
parenting if my trunk was that small I
wouldn't draw attention to myself pal
Manny perpetuates trunk Envy which in a
few thousand years will evolve it to
something else come up a mob see it is a
weakened by Manny's character
introduction and not the herd of animals
that has been stopping by for presumably
a few hours because you know the plot
they do this every year
sits family abandons him every year yet
he still manages to find them so they
can abandon him again and he doesn't
anticipate it for the next year isn't
there anyone who cares about shit the
sloth Sid says his name in species while
talking to himself because nuance
position is for suckers ah that creature
that walks by must have some powerful
butthole in order to shoot his fecal
matter to that location because I
watched him scuttle by that spot and he
did not defecate I can't believe it
fresh wild greens these Rhino creatures
don't seem to be too worried about
migrating with the herd which is great
because now their available tool easily
manufacture some conflict I'll
double-check but I'm pretty sure this is
the first children's movie to ever have
literally splattered on a characters
face now even though these rhinos are
super pissed off they feel the need to
give the sloth a head start
don't let them in tell me they have very
long fingernails that I didn't see if
not I don't know how they will impale
him with a flat shovel and a wishbone
four horns if either of you make it
across that sinkhole in front of you you
get the sloth why would they even be
remotely concerned that this is actually
a sinkhole Sid literally just ran over
it when there's plenty of room for them
to just walk around the not sinkhole how
do they think Manny got over their
[Music]
symbol you and me two bachelors knocking
about in that wild I guess at the blue
sky pitch meeting for this movie Michael
Wilson just said remember last year when
DreamWorks did Trek let's do that and we
can teach kids bad science win-win this
sloth is pretty fast they probably
should have just made him a fictional
prehistoric ferret or something instead
of making him a notoriously slow
creature that moves normally the mammoth
is Manny the mammoth this must be Percy
the person also collars hats these
Paleolithic people are very
fashion-forward tightly tied my hands
and feet and they gag me with a field
mouse and barricade the cave door and
covered their tracks went to water so
I'd lose a Centon after all that sit was
able to find them again
his entire family must be as dumb as he
is force it to be able to track them
down after they went through all that
trouble also if they did all that last
year then why the hell did sits family
just leave without doing anything to him
this year and why the because this year
the year he loses his family for good
nanny is able to turn around in a
shelter even though there was no way you
could actually do that well almost
nothing has happened so far time for
scratch it's really saying something
when the most memorable parts of your
movie are the little transitional scenes
with a squirrel that have nothing to do
with the actual plot of the movie how
did you not see or hear the mom
approaching an attempt there seemed to
only be four men in this camp which
might be a problem if there weren't just
four saber-toothed cats it's literally
unbelievable this saber-toothed tiger
hasn't caught up to this woman running
with a baby yet and
you picked this hair off my shoulder and
says look if you're gonna have an extra
mating dance at least pick a female with
the same color powder that's racist the
director said let's have your character
eat an apple it'll make him look like
even more of an asshole okay she's a lot
but the baby is definitely dead up the
the baby survived that fall and
subsequent turning of the waterfall Nana
the human understanding listen very
carefully I'm not going any enunciates
through his nose hi I'm fine I'm gonna
die seems like an unnecessary way to get
this child back to its people even
though it would take longer they could
just walk baby giggles through a
perilous situation cliche what kind of
bullshit is this you mean he's somehow
track where the baby was downriver
literal slapstick well unless you know
how to track you're never gonna reach
them before the pass closes up with snow
why is knowing how to track a factor
Mandy just pointed to where they need to
go slight seems to be the only necessary
treat for this journey would tag you I
said tigey YG's gonna lead the way Manny
with holds as planned which creates this
awkward moment that I think is supposed
to be funny I suggest you watch your
back cuz I'll be chewing on it watching
it won't do much good at that point
I've eaten things that didn't complain
as much I would hope that the things
Diego eats wouldn't complain because
they would be already dead Hey wearing
one of the baby thing is Manny has a
pretty solid grasp of the English
language but doesn't know the word
diaper check for poop I think the entire
screenplay was written around this one
line hey Bill did we animate any
characters getting on their face not
sure Tom but I throw some on the mammoth
just in case tweed there was no way that
was clean he clearly hasn't been changed
in over 24 hours
Disney very famously animates characters
to be as cute as possible Fox on the
other hand is like NAT where's the baby
there is is peekaboo a game that
saber-tooth cats commonly play I don't
remember seeing that at the Museum of
Natural History
I bet he's hungry how are they not all
hungry I don't think any of them have
eaten in days
Dodos were not anywhere near in North
America they were pretty much stuck on
one island in the Indian Ocean
also 99% of the species that have
existed on earth are extinct yet the
dodo has this reputation for being
insanely stupid
mammoths are extent also but mani isn't
hopping around acting like a fool hey
can we have our melon back since when
was this every year melon
how that they all know at the same time
that Sid was trying to steal another
melon they might be done but they have a
keen sense of when someone is touching
their melons this watermelon dodo
sequence with its music and madcap
hijinks feels like it should be
delightful but it's not
I said Diego has no idea how watermelons
work a shelf all CID is full from eating
a little bit of watermelon after not
eating for an extended time Diego can
smell when someone is finally going to
sleep apparently dragging down helpless
infants too difficult for you so they've
been following them this whole time or
did the movie just a sign for them to
operate here so they could have this
conversation that reminds us that Diego
is still a bad guy
Soto's getting tired of waiting why
can't Soto hunt down this baby by
himself I'll never understand these
villains who really want something then
leave it up to others to get it for them
Sid and the floozies use a tar pit a
natural phenomenon that notoriously
trapped and killed prehistoric animals
as a Jacuzzi also the whole point of
this movie is that Sid got left behind
and Manny decided not to migrate with
the rest of the animals so how the kid
Sid run into two female sloths in this
general vicinity baby's eyes have tar
repellent powers also the baby would
totally be dead at this point and
Sidney's lady friends would be close
behind
nanny I need him to do what exactly they
already know you have him his presence
would just be awkward of your
relationship with these sloth women went
any further how did these rhinos
suddenly show up out of the blue having
our heroes traveled some distance and
some terrain that would be impossible
for these assholes to suddenly happen
upon their camp hey hey does this look
like a petting zoo to you hey hey have
you ever seen a petting zoo or zoo
period three two one
sure is faithful what could sit choose
to lay here I guess it was the only
feasible way to reveal that this is Old
Faithful giving us context of their
location even though that completely
screws with the fact that we saw dodo
birds earlier who were indigenous to the
islands in the Indian Ocean the Sid
picks up a somehow already completed
snowball modern architecture Manny knows
about architecture but he doesn't know
about diapers during the Ice Age snow
didn't stick to animal fur who knew
Diego wastes his time by covering up a
footprint that he could claim as his own
and then waste his time some more by
making the single four toad human
footprint in the snow because fake
seeing a lone human footprint in the
snow doesn't immediately raise suspicion
you know because prehistoric humans have
such epically long strides aren't they
on a time crunch
didn't someone say earlier well unless
you know how to track you're never going
to reach them before the pass closes up
with snow
yeah they decided to take this time to
ice-skate where the hell is the thrush
hold on an animal being able to speak
English or can the squirrel actually
speak English but he just prefers to
communicate with charades
because he knows charades just as well
as the rest of our characters can speak
English it knows he uh pachyderm
backslap many designs to be as
unobservant as sid in this moment based
on his Anatomy making and throwing a
snowball should be very difficult for
Manny yep he is able to produce and
throw this Boulder sized snowball move
sloth movie perpetuates myth that slight
yelling can cause large sheets of ice to
crumble the group is concerned about the
chandelier of icicles even though the
area they are standing in is this big
the ice from earlier looks a lot like
rocks now it was nice of this cave to
freeze in the shape of a Natural History
Museum also aren't we going to do a
whole dawn of the dinosaurs story later
who the hell is this guy hey nice sloth
evolutionary chart I wonder who's alive
millions of years to collect all these
guys and piece this all together movie
goes to the trouble to reference Star
Trek but gives us a generic ass flying
saucer instead of any of the thousands
of ships in that universe as reference
isn't the baby ahead of them look what
the baby survived the room of ice spikes
also it's convenient that this ice froze
and a fun slide formation manny is
behind the baby when he launches into
the air and then suddenly he's in front
of the baby so he could be calm
who's up for out - Diego stole SIDS line
or maybe SIDS irritating demeanor is
like an airborne illness Manny is almost
to the exit of the cave then in no time
he's back with San Diego looking at the
painting
Manny may secretly be the fastest animal
in whatever fantasy version of the world
they are a backstory cave painting they
would have just done a standard
flashback but that would be too
expensive to animate
yeah but put this scenario to occur
Manny would have to live in a world
where death is possible did Diego and
Sid see that animation also they seem to
know why Manny is upset did the cape men
draw a touching portrait of a loving
mammoth family before killing two-thirds
of it that's some dark man hypothermia
must be completely psychological because
Percy here seems just fun also was it
not possible for this era of man to grow
a full beard because I feel like the
five o'clock shadow look isn't entirely
plausible here and I guess I just
couldn't get through this without a
volcano erupting huh it's like roland
emmerich or the ten robots who copied
roland emmerich on san andreas consulted
on this movie i'm able to look past some
of the scientific inaccuracies of this
movie but the last time I checked the
melting point of ice is significantly
lower than the melting point of rocks if
the rocks are hot enough to be lava how
the because there any ice anywhere near
it and I'm starting to think the
animators of this movie did their
research by playing the Bowser levels of
Super Mario
Manny's trunk was extended as far as it
could go but it still has enough length
to reach out
for Diego as he's falling down and has
enough strength to grab a freaking tiger
out of midair convenient and possibly
life-saving Kaiser is convenient no one
touches the mammoth until I get that
baby it's going to be a lot easier for
them to get the baby if the mammoth
isn't in the way you can still eat it as
popcorn why is this bad really how can
he keep the skis on while he walked I
was he able to jump out of the snow with
two sticks on his legs I thought this
movie wasn't drying the whole time but
now I really know what not trying looks
like just just this whole part Sid
brings the baby over to where he knows
the Sabres are they are starving but
they just saw the mammoth get lucky and
kill their leader with some icicles and
they don't want to chance it because who
knows if there are more icicles between
this moment in the moment earlier with
the impossible lava river movie has one
too many death fake-out scenes the
speedy seems to know what's going on
this tense moment is brought to you by
no king reason why would you hide the
baby and allow a hundred time to kill
you before you made your dramatic reveal
I mean come on seriously
I've seen this woolly mammoth talk have
human emotions and have the capacity to
solve problems and it still might be the
stupidest fooling the mammoth that has
ever lived
yeah stop he's just making a dramatic
reveal of my baby we are fools none of
the humans are surprised that the sloth
can pick up and hug a baby like a person
also interspecies hugging okay see these
happy humans walking in the distance
here now the baby plays peekaboo and
sits somehow sees it fun but the sin
here is after another 20 seconds of
walking can Diego can see it too you
know humans can't talk yeah but at least
we actually learn how to talk you and
your ancestors never do
blue sky I paint for this fucking song
so they are gonna get their money's
worth even if this piece of ice with
Scrat in it broke off very recently how
could it survive that long in the
tropics
that's not how deserted islands work we
spend two minutes with this fucking rat
even though the movie has already ended
I'm ridiculous lack of elastic today
[Music]
see I when I shall never be Kings hey my
baby you know what else everybody like
posse
have you ever met a person you say hey
let me get some coffee they say hell no
I don't like no poppies poppies are
delicious yeah when somebody loved me
everything was beautiful every hour
spent together within my gonna be a pair
right here off for this damn right here
what's going on where are we the
interchange roles you're right hard good
[Music]
but extremely juice I told you to knock
it off easy action go to him look at
that our little guys growing up you know
what big boy you're growing up growing
up
yeah did that is the production for you
cuz your grows up and your grows up and
your drums up what killed the dinosaurs
yeah hey